[Music]
in traditional versus fusion news
i know it's gonna happen what's gonna
happen some white lady opened a chinese
restaurant or some [ __ ]
right yeah i don't like it when you guys
go
you asked
i wanted you to be wrong it's more fun
when you're wrong is it a white lady or
a white dude it really is a white lady
being a chinese restaurant are you
serious maybe i read this [ __ ] somewhere
yeah because that's
pretty popular submitted by claire from
chicago
oh hi hi uh yeah like you said another
new chinese restaurant is drawing
backlash for its
healthier option marketing yo but i love
trejo's tacos i mean
danny trejo is mexican but he made like
an organic like
mexican taco street taco place and it's
like vegan options because the sun's
vegan and it's so good
and you know what it's just expensive
it's expensive what's lower your prices
what's the problem here
dude he's in hollywood though bro it's
expensive to operate yeah and it's
organic they just slap that label on can
you charge whatever you want and it's
really expensive
new york restaurant called lucky lease
the founder is a
nutritionist and blogger named ariel
hespel
and she named the restaurant after her
husband
named lee anyway so she was saying that
this is for people who love to eat
chinese food and
love the benefit that it will actually
make them feel good was her husband
chinese
i don't know oh should be like luckily
luckily it tastes good and luckily it's
organic it makes you feel good so she's
like saying like you know chinese food
is very unhealthy for you right but
guess what if you come to my restaurant
it's super clean
super clean like healthy and all that
[ __ ] right a white person made it so
it's obviously nice and clean
yeah yeah so she's saying wasn't she
saying that msg is like one of the main
things and like that's supposed to be
to be bad for you or whatever so
apparently you didn't
generally recognizes msgs safe
and it has never been able to confirm
that it causes
the effects which is yeah all that was
pseudoscience now read that [ __ ] about
diet coke because the same [ __ ]
that's that's what i'm saying dude no
but the
the myth about msg has been that that's
why i agree with you but i'm
saying that in the culture everyone
hears msg and they go that's bad just
like how they go
oh organic so much better than this
other [ __ ] even though there's nothing
proven about that [ __ ] either
steve nicky drink water i do drink more
yeah so wait if people know chinese
restaurants there are vegan or
vegetarian
and non-msg like the problem here is
that
she is using language that puts down
classic chinese-american uh cooking as
greasy and unhealthy
so that's why she's like well look at us
we're not that crap that you're used to
kind of thing
that's that's exactly like what how
people are perceiving
that's why they're mad that's how
they're perceiving her message i think
they're mad because a white lady is
opening a chinese restaurant right
let's be real i'd be mad if it was
disgusting
because like mexican food traditionally
is cooked and lard
and like you know like it's just like
not it isn't healthy yep
so if someone like danny trejo opened a
really healthy mexican food restaurant
it's
it's like okay yeah i mean those are if
it was a white guy who's like hey no
lard here or whatever and it's good then
who cares yeah but i think
generally people when they think of
chinese food they think of orange
chicken
or something the meme stuff yeah the
general sews even though that's not even
real
so they don't have to express yeah like
because to me chinese
food can be healthy if you just get the
stir-fried vegetables
and like steamed fish or something so
the trope is that it's unhealthy that's
what i'm saying
i think the trope for white people or
non-asians
i think the confusion is she's speaking
to that audience
yeah and asians are getting mad because
it's like what are you talking about
yeah because china's not even obese
exactly yeah and there are vegan and um
vegetarian restaurants
because there is like food buddhism yeah
they don't eat
meat and they don't eat yeah that's why
they have tofu
but dude even when you go to chinese
restaurants and they have that little
symbol next to their [ __ ] where it's
like hey this one's got the green
icon next to it because it's like
healthier for you yeah it's like that's
what they're saying they're saying like
this stuff's the unhealthy [ __ ] this
stuff's a healthy [ __ ]
this lady's like hey what if all my
shit's the green one it's all healthy
[ __ ]
like it's not [ __ ] that mean yeah i
don't even know what her exact quote is
so it's kind of hard to
say make a comment on it she said that
her local
chinese restaurant makes her thirst so
thirsty
and that her fingers swell the next day
that's the sojum
there's a lot of salt yeah so then she's
saying she can't even put her
her rings on and she said you know the
morning after you go to your favorite
chinese restaurant or sushi
joint and you feel bloated your eyes are
puffy in your wrinkles it's from the soy
sauce
she's right dude the soy sauce gets gets
me all puffy it's the sodium really
yeah i've never heard of that like i
never yeah
why do they have the low sodium one bro
the one with the green top
i thought people just you know most
restaurants don't even put low sodium
they just have that bottle and they put
the regular [ __ ] that's how smart
that's hella smart but it's the same
price i thought the rice was making me
feel bloated from sushi and then i
stopped
doing this the soy sauce just for one
time just to see and it was the soy
sauce yeah
the rice was fine wow yeah yeah so then
hey wait maybe
it could be the gluten in this one it
could be gluten sensitive yeah
but it is a sodium but sodium is is like
a swelling thing it doesn't doesn't
so there is gluten in soy sauce yeah
what if like genetically culturally
right we
react differently to salt and different
levels of salt
and carbohydrates alcohol things like
that because it can't happen right like
for example
um asians didn't evolve with the cow so
we
a lot of us are lactose and only areas
that have
like milk products in their culture for
a long long time they can handle
milk until adult age why can't you drink
though because japanese whiskey and sake
is so good
yeah japanese whiskey's like no i don't
know i did not drink i don't know
japanese whiskey's like some of the best
in the world i never tried uh
uh like sake and stuff oh you should try
because it's rice it's rice wine yeah
yeah yeah what about soju
i don't know i tried a little bit but i
don't like i just stay away from it
because i never had great experiences
with alcohol
but yeah things like that right and um
carbohydrates i think a lot of
uh east asian cultures are able to take
a large amount of carbohydrates because
of
like rice and things like that isn't
their main diet like by
60 70 percent but you have you know
other cultures that are like
very sensitive to carbohydrates if this
was an asian lady opening this
restaurant nobody would give a [ __ ] true
that's all that's all it is yeah that's
exactly true because people are saying
uh quote keep your gentrified
white-washed and cultural appropriated
food to yourself
and then olivia the actor yeah
she said don't [ __ ] on our culture and
then profit from it
why is prophet so bad to people jesus
christ in the food world i don't think
you have to be of that race to create
the food like there's a lot of great
mexican sushi chefs that i i personally
go to and you don't have to be japanese
they're good
you know or like there's by me there's
mexican sushi restaurants
so yeah yeah so so in if you're in the
food world i think it's not
you're you're open to a lot of different
things because
there's like there's this one um he's on
netflix but there's this one
it's called like ivan ramen or whatever
this is one jewish guy right
he lived in japan for like 30 years he
opened up a ramen shop
there he won ramen awards in japan and
he opened up one in new york the problem
here
is the fact that she is playing into the
racist
tropes of being of chinese food being
unhealthy how is that racist
what's racist just call it something not
chinese food then
just be like it's a fusion restaurant
whatever yeah she said fusion
but the racist part explains to me i
don't understand that this is the fact
that she's saying like oh you know how
you feel like [ __ ] after you eat chinese
food well my food's not going to make
you feel like shaking because it's clean
but there's like i said when you go to
some chinese restaurants and [ __ ]
authentic chinese restaurants in la they
even say like this shit's the healthy
one this shit's not the healthiest
so like for me i i love making japanese
food all the time and i'm not japanese
but i don't say that i can make japanese
food better than the japanese
or you say it so that's what people are
taking wait if you have a restaurant
you're like number one
japanese food and you're just some white
guy you're just advertising your [ __ ]
business like everyone else
i think that's where it gets tricky
because like world's best or whatever
yeah so so for example like putting down
the traditional way of cooking and
saying it's gross enough right for you
i haven't seen a quote there where she
says it's [ __ ] gross yeah let me know
that i'm just going off of what
what is being told to me yeah that's the
gray area here where it sounds like that
exactly it's like you know the
traditional real chinese food that you
guys been eating for like
hundreds of years and [ __ ] that shitty
that makes you feel like
that would be tight right but that's
basically what she's saying here
and i think that's probably what is it
basically what you're saying because i
haven't heard a quote yet no no no
that's what people are taking it yeah
is there a quote here's a quote uh we
heard you're obsessed with lo mein but
rarely eat it you said
it makes you feel bloated and icky the
next day well wait until you slurp up
our hi
not too oily or salty so racist no no no
the word the wording it's the wording
it's it's her saying you're bloated
you're icky disgusting gross whatever
right
there's a negative attachment to
traditional chinese food
so that's easily you could easily take
it
as oh like you're saying that the real
[ __ ] is the bad [ __ ]
and your [ __ ] is the better [ __ ] to
clarify it's it seems like she's
focusing
mainly on chinese american cooking not
chinese from like china
to clarify it doesn't matter because
i've been to china hong kong and there's
authentic chinese food here too so i
don't know the difference
is american chinese panda express i
don't [ __ ] know right like
so the only i'm just trying to figure
out why people are pissed right yeah and
i can
clearly say like it's because of her
choices of
words yeah to how she's describing the
food but saying that you feel icky the
next day after eating
so here's the thing though you can do
that if you're describing
a food of your own culture right
especially if there's not enough
fair representation of that dude i love
mexican food right okay
i eat it i feel icky the next day it
just is
because a lot of it like nikki said the
best [ __ ] you're gonna have to deal with
the repercussions of mexicans going hey
[ __ ] you steve
i don't like that that's yeah right
that's what i'm worried about in the
culture now you can't just say
something without everyone clapping back
with racism
well i don't think it's racist i think
she made a mistake in not being tactful
yeah but tiff just said she thought it
was racist so i i wouldn't
say you said it was racist i personally
don't think
people are saying right okay i wasn't
sure i i just want to know
not me personally mike i'm trying to
dissect is how they could come to that
conclusion
because obviously to me it's it's a
stretch and it's stupid
right but it's like also what are these
people thinking
to drive drive themselves to be like to
to
to go to that conclusion like it's like
why where does it come from
because you can't just write people off
and say they're being idiots it's like
there's a good reason why people are
pissed
i mean eddie wang yeah so he's a he's a
pretty known
food so this is his comments i mean you
guys can read it or
someone okay well i'm not even mad he's
not even mad but he's diving in all
capitals
he's very i'm not even mad because
anybody anyone paying money for this
outdoor voices baked orange cauliflower
deserves it
this is the fire fest of food and
wellness nothing about it is chinese or
well besides the fact that it's an
attempt at the ancient chinese art of
bootlegging
but this isn't even as dope as a pair of
pants
with four stripes people look at your
bootleg pants and can't even see the
reference
which is curious to me because aren't
y'all supposed to be good at pinterest
boards and [ __ ]
the restaurant is literally the nobody
meme
you guys get that yeah the no nobody
does this and then oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but me i have
i personally have a difficult time
understanding where that line is
because i'm totally okay with non-asians
opening up
asian restaurants because there are
examples of great chefs that respect
japanese food chinese food or whatever
they spend years to study it
and they want to share a little piece of
that in their hometown so they go back
to
i don't know like tulsa oklahoma where
there is no japanese food
and then they'll open that restaurant up
this happened in
um austin texas maybe they're in a
couple maybe that's okay
and then that person opening the
japanese restaurant isn't
talking [ __ ] about authentic but i don't
see what she's really doing as talking
[ __ ] either
i'm just i think she's making the
assumption that all chinese food is
greasy and makes you feel
and it's dirty and then that's when the
people reading are like well i eat this
it doesn't make me feel like that's
right it's an uninformed
i mean so basically what she's doing is
going based off of a stupid trope right
that chinese food is greasy right or or
whatever
and it can be if you eat cantonese food
but we all know
as being asians we know like a lot of
other [ __ ] that doesn't
it's like steamed healthy like clean
[ __ ] that it
exists right so i think that's the issue
here is that
it's just like she's playing into the
trope it's in it's a it's because race
is attached to it because when peop not
vegan brands are like hey you know how
you feel all gross after eating dairy
well eat this non-dairy food
well for me i can digest dairy just fine
like i don't have any problem digesting
dairy
i chose to to eat non-dairy because i
just like don't want to eat dairy
anymore but i have no problem with it
but a lot of people do have a problem
digesting dairy so just because i don't
have a problem with it doesn't mean
the majority of the demographic that
wants to try a non-dairy food
does doesn't have a problem with it it's
just that there's a race attached to
this so if she says
i agree she didn't say chinese food and
she said orange chicken
you think that would have changed some
[ __ ] dude some people even say orange
chicken's not chinese food and [ __ ] you
know i'm saying like no no but if she
said a dish
of chinese american cuisine like
something that was like that would be
better yeah yeah so it's like what if uh
uh you're like you know when you eat
orange chicken and it's like fried and
then like it's too sweet and then
whatever
well guess what come here it's not like
that to conclude
she responded with saying a number of
comments have stated that
by saying our chinese food is made with
clean cooking techniques and it makes
you feel great that we are commenting
negatively on all chinese food when we
talk about
our food we are not talking about other
restaurants we are only talking about
lucky leaves
she's promoting your business yeah yeah
just saying like you know every
restaurant has the right to tout the
positives of its food
we plan to continue communicating that
our food is made with high quality
ingredients and techniques that are
intended to make you feel great
my restaurant is number one best
restaurant the guy across from me who
has a restaurant
sucks my [ __ ] is awesome yeah that's
basically what the tactic was
but i think you're right it's the whole
white lady thing chinese food white lady
representing chinese food and saying her
chinese food is better than the actual
chinese people
it's so easy to rip on like a mommy
blogger type person who's like oh you
know these are the healthy options
everyone's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you but i mean is it really
a big problem though what's a big
problem this whole thing no people are
looking for outrage
because i want to try it i think it's
stupid i want to try it yeah can we
postmate it you're stupid as [ __ ]
i i think so too that's why like when
you were saying like i said it was
racist i'm like oh
the times that i report a story i'm
always talking about the perspective
from the article but it's always
misconstrued to
to come out like it's my own opinion
when it isn't no yeah this is not my
opinion i will let you know when it's my
opinion
hell yeah girl get it that was just what
the article was saying
[Music]
you